self-portrait hello
it is Friday here on its grace and I
don't have a friary this week because
I've just recently got a new camera I
have currently arrived to playlist live
in Orlando Florida which if you don't
know is YouTube you mentioned down here
and it is Florida there's a lot of
people to see and things to do so I
thought I would make this video really
quickly for you before I potentially go
out to Benihana tonight which is dinner
theater for the classiest of folks I'm
going on my tumblr to ask you guys what
do you have questions about this is just
gonna be a straight-up QA let's do it
and get to it and also let's just
[Music]
don't mince words mince onions
where he'd repeated wait wait reflects
the heat meaning not all the warmth is
let out why are you not spending this
time thinking about your future so that
not all the time runs out you can do
something really positive with that
brain of yours
what was your prom dress like I had the
most Jersey ass of from justice it was a
black halter dress with like sparkles on
it and it liked it this kind of like
flamenco ruffle thing at the bottom I
think I bought it from the Deb not a
woman a store that I mean if you
personify the name Deb into a store
that's probably what the Deb was
actually like I got my hair done at the
JC Penney hair salon and they pooped it
like they put it up and it was when
spiky things were really popular in
girls hair and then I went over to the
Macy's makeup counter I got my makeup
done and they put so much silver
eyeshadow all over me and I got home and
I was like so upset and so my mom helped
me take it down because we were from
South Jersey but I didn't want everyone
to know that if you couldn't have a
child with any piece of furniture which
piece of furniture would it be and why
definitely not a lazy boy it's gonna say
a flat-screen TV but then it's like a
large child Hemi flat-chested I would
say an armoire
but like the kid needs legs to hurt News
what if he's Curt's out I don't know I
don't know this is gonna make me look at
Ethan Allen very differently now do you
have any songs for special situation
like a song to cry to or jogging summer
karaoke song well for instance the song
that I listen to on repeat during camp
Takota for the scenes that I had to be
really emotional in I listen to skinny
love by Bonnie bear
and I would look myself to cry
acting how much wood could a woodchuck
chuck if a woodchuck would chuck wood I
don't understand why they wouldn't there
a woodchuck but I default that should be
their job
what is it wood why what's a woodchuck
would chuck what's it do
what's it do it just exists is like the
weird step cousin of a porcupine and a
skunk and a beaver what how do you
overthrow a country maybe try throwing
overhand I know that I get more power
when I throw overhand than underhand how
can they spend less time forecasting on
the Internet
that's a well don't be so hard on
yourself you know if you have your
tumblr tab open and spending on some lip
but then like have a tab that's like how
do I do stocks open at the same time
it'll make you it'll give the placebo
effect that you have business happening
in the background of all of the gifs I
ate half of a cake now what do I do
apologize to the rest of the birthday
party what was your favorite childhood
show grace Tim and I used to watch
supermarket sweep and shop til you drop
back to back every day after school and
those are the two greatest shows highly
recommend you tubing any clips you can
from those shows they're so great okay
there are some answers to your questions
I hope that this was enjoyable for you
I'll try and take some footage at
playlist over the weekend but if I don't
hey I didn't promise it I said I'd try
you can't spell try it without why I
don't know how do you like your eggs
frozen